Papa avait l'habitude de dire et je lui ai donné ma parole, il
disait Joey, souviens-toi qu'un travail,
c'est bien plus qu'un salaire, c'est une question de
dignité, c'est
ta place dans la communauté, c'est
qui tu es, c'est être capable d'avoir l'air bien.
enfant dans les yeux et dit chérie, tout
ira bien et je le pense
[Musique]
je me souviens de ma mère, ma douce dame, qui me
regardait après que nous ayons quitté l'hôpital
et disait à Joey, de tout ce
qui t'arrive de terrible,
quelque chose de bien viendra si tu  cherchez
assez attentivement,
elle avait raison
[Musique]
je me souviens encore aujourd'hui à quel point le bégaiement était
déshumanisant à quel point embarrassant à quel
point cela remettait en question dans mon
esprit ainsi que
mes capacités
[Musique]
quand Barack et moi grandissions
là-bas  une compréhension implicite aux
États-Unis
que si vous preniez vos responsabilités, vous auriez
une chance d'avoir
une vie meilleure et
les valeurs derrière ce marché étaient les
valeurs qui nous ont façonnés,
ainsi que beaucoup d'entre vous.
[Musique]
j'étais à Washington pour embaucher  le personnel,
j'ai reçu un appel téléphonique, ma femme et mes trois
enfants faisaient des courses de Noël, un
semi-remorque a tué ma
femme et ma fille
et ils n'étaient pas sûrs que mes fils
vivraient,
alors
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Rires]
c'est une élection extraordinaire  le
peuple américain est prêt
je suis prêt barack est prêt c'est son
heure c'est
notre heure c'est l'heure de l'Amérique
le taoiseach en sait beaucoup sur sa
mère euh a vécu
à long island pendant environ 10 ans euh que Dieu
ait son âme
et  euh euh même si elle attend, ta mère est
toujours
ta mère est toujours en vie est-ce que ton père est
décédé que Dieu bénisse son âme
[Musique]
écoute tout le monde sait qui est Donald Trump
nous devons lui faire savoir qui nous sommes nous
choisissons
l'espoir plutôt que la peur nous choisissons la
science plutôt que la fiction
nous  choisissez l'unité plutôt que la division
et devinez ce que nous choisissons la vérité plutôt que les mensonges
[Musique]
je veux juste que vous sachiez que j'avais la permission
de serrer
Lonnie dans mes bras
[Musique]
à ce jour, je regrette de ne pas avoir pu trouver
un moyen  pour
lui obtenir l'audition qu'elle méritait compte tenu
du courage dont elle a fait preuve en
nous contactant
l'audition qu'elle méritait était une audition
où elle était respectée
où le ton de l'interrogatoire
n'était pas hostile et insulté
où le fait qu'elle s'était manifestée
était reconnu  en tant qu'acte de courage en
soi
[Musique],
c'est la campagne la plus inhabituelle à mon
avis dans l'histoire moderne,
mais je pars du principe
que je vais suivre les ordres du doc
non seulement pour moi mais pour le  pays et
euh cela signifie que
je ne vais pas organiser de rassemblements
après des mois à ne rien faire d'
autre que prédire que le virus
disparaîtrait ou peut-être que si vous buviez de l'eau de Javel, tout
irait bien.
Trump a simplement abandonné
[Musique]
vous êtes  le pire président que l'Amérique ait
jamais eu,
laisse-moi juste te dire Jill, j'ai fait plus
en 47 mois, j'ai fait plus que
toi
en 47 ans,
le président actuel a masqué les
ténèbres américaines pendant trop longtemps,
trop de colère aussi  beaucoup de peur trop de
division
ici et maintenant je vous donne ma parole
si vous me confiez la présidence je
ferai appel au meilleur d'entre nous
pas au pire je serai un allié de la
lumière
pas des ténèbres